le cinéma français l'attendaient depuis
21 ans la palme d'or a été décerné ce
soir à laurent cantet pour son film
entre les murs une palme qui reflète
bien l'esprit du jury et de son
président sean penn
retour sur cette cérémonie et sur les
autres prix natali et r ceci fut la
deuxième décision à l'unanimité
un film extraordinaire entre les murs de
laurent cantet un choc pour le
rencontrer sa jeune équipe mais quel
merveilleux choc son film projeté hier
seulement 1 visiblement conquis et la
critique et le jury la remise de cette
fameuse d'or est un grand moment
d'émotion
voilà ici soir tous ensemble c'est un
moment très très très très fort pour
nous entre les murs raconte la vie d'une
classe plutôt difficile et celle de son
professeur qui joue son propre rôle
une forme cinématographique fort et
original
il a pété les plombs c'est grave
il a littéralement habité son personnage
che guevara une ressemblance
hallucinante un jeu formidable benicio
del toro a incontestablement mérité son
prix d'interprétation
un prix dont la rumeur circulait déjà
depuis plusieurs jours
je tiens à dédier ce prix jaguar à
l'homme qui a inspiré le film che
guevara le prix d'interprétation
féminine à lui était attribuée à la
comédienne sandra corveloni pour sa
prestation dans le film
lynn a dépassé du brésilien walter
salles s elle y interprète une mère
courage dans un bidonville de sao paulo
et d'une et 2,2 et 2,3 pour les frères
dardenne
cette fois ci ce n'est pas une palme
mais le prix du meilleur scénario qu'ils
ont obtenu pour leur film le silence de
lorna deux films italiens également été
récompensé il divo pour le prix du jury
et gomorra pour le grand prix du
festival
on retiendra également deux hommages
rendus à deux grands acteurs pour
l'ensemble de leur carrière clint
eastwood qui n'était pas présent à la
cérémonie et catherine deneuve
je suis très touché très touché très ému
au final un palmarès sans paillettes
puisque tous les signes récompensés ont
une vraie connotation politique ou
sociale des films réalisés comme le
souhaitait sean penn par des personnes
conscientes du monde dans lequel elles
vivent